acabas de comprar una lata enorme de
chiles rojos super picantes que pesa 3
kilogramos y cuelgas la lata usando dos
cuerdas al techo ya que no quieres que
nadie agarre tu lata de chiles super
picantes y tú quieres conocer cuál es la
atención en ambas cuerdas
ese es el ángulo que las cuerdas forman
con el techo cuáles van a ser estas dos
tensiones bueno este problema es difícil
y es un problema bastante picante vamos
a comenzar con algo un poquito más
sencillo y vamos a ir aumentando la
complejidad y encontrar lo que queremos
y vamos a hacerlo de esta manera porque
aunque parezca que un problema al
principio es bastante difícil y luce
bastante diferente que un problema
sencillo el proceso para encontrar la
solución va a ser el mismo y yo quiero
que aprendan a no dejarse distraer por
los detalles aún cuando parezca que el
proceso es diferente la estrategia
general para resolverlo siempre
misma vamos a comenzar con algo más
fácil aquí tenemos una linda manzanita
esta manzana roja pesa 3 kilogramos y lo
ponemos así para mantener la masa esta
manzana está colgada del techo y
queremos conocer la atención de esta
cuerda bueno este problema se ve
bastante sencillo y aún cuando se vea
sencillo vamos a realizar todos y cada
uno de los pasos que no nos llevará
mucho tiempo pero para que se
acostumbren al procedimiento para
resolver esto vamos a dibujar nuestro
diagrama de fuerzas la fuerza de la
gravedad que se ejerce sobre esta
manzana ya que la fuerza de gravedad se
ejerce en todo lo que esté cercano a la
tierra fuerza de gravedad es igual a m
por g y tenemos la fuerza de atención
que no empuja recuerden que no podemos
empujar con una cuerda esta fuerza de
tensión va a apuntar hacia arriba y la
llamamos t
este es el primer paso siempre vamos a
dibujar nuestro diagrama de fuerzas y
ahora vamos a usar la segunda ley de
newton ya sé
para la dirección vertical o la
dirección horizontal o ambas si es que
así lo requieren la segunda ley de
newton luce así la aceleración en cierta
dirección es igual a la fuerza neta en
esa dirección dividida entre la masa
pues cuál es la dirección que nos
interesa aquí se ve bastante obvio ya
que es la dirección vertical ya que no
tenemos ninguna fuerza en la dirección
horizontal y aquí esta aceleración bueno
si tenemos esta manzanita que no se está
moviendo y nada más está colgada aquí no
se va a estar acelerando pero si a lo
mejor yo tuviera aquí algún elevador o
algún cohete o algo que me estuviera
moviendo este objeto lo podríamos poner
acá pero esto simplemente está colgando
del techo por lo que esa aceleración va
a ser igual a cero que es igual a la
fuerza neta bueno tenemos la atención
que va hacia arriba como lo vamos a
poner aquí bueno pues por unas razones
que dibujamos este diagrama de fuerzas
no fue solo para divertirnos un rato la
estrategia es que dibujemos nuestras
fuerzas porque esto nos permite saber
cuál es la fuerza neta que tenemos que
poner aquí arriba si no está aquí no lo
puedo poner aquí arriba y si está aquí
lo tengo que poner acá si es en esta
dirección mi intención es vertical y
esta es la dirección vertical de la
fuerza neta
pongo mi intención acá y voy a definir
que la dirección hacia arriba va a ser
positiva y las direcciones hacia abajo
van a ser negativas ya que me interesa
tener la atención positiva la fuerza de
gravedad va hacia abajo por lo que
escribo menos m porque lo divido entre
la masa y ahora simplemente despejo la
atención y ese es el proceso dibujamos
nuestro diagrama de fuerzas usamos la
segunda ley de newton y despejamos la
fuerza que nos interesa en este caso la
detención multiplico a ambos lados por m
sigo teniendo cero en el lado izquierdo
de la igualdad y me queda de menos m por
g
y si despejo te voy a tener algo que
realmente no nos va a sorprender
es igual a la masa por la gravedad y
bueno esto podría ser bastante obvio
podríamos haber calculado esto
directamente sin hacer todos estos pasos
ya que la atención está equilibrando la
fuerza de gravedad pero porque hicimos
todo este desarrollo paso por paso
puedes porque en este caso fue igual a m
por g pero no siempre va a ser así si
queremos saber qué hacer cuando esto no
es igual a m por g pues tenemos que
saber cómo aplicar este proceso completo
cuando no se cumpliría esto bueno pues
imagínense que aquí tenemos dos
tensiones en lugar de una imaginemos que
alguien está jalando hacia abajo la
manzana y la está jalando con una fuerza
extra de 5 newtons y esto va a estirar
más la cuerda y la va a poner más tensa
que hago en este caso bueno tengo que
agregar una fuerza más a mi diagrama de
fuerzas lo hacemos aquí tenemos 5
newtons se dirigen hacia abajo
por lo que aquí en mi fuerza neta voy a
poner estos 5 newtons con signo negativo
ya que está con la dirección hacia abajo
y aplico mi álgebra como la vez anterior
multiplico ambos lados por m y aquí voy
a tener otro menos 5 newtons y para
despejar x te voy a sumar m porque en
ambos lados y también voy a sumar 5
newtons en ambos lados por lo que esta
va a ser mi fuerza de tensión si
incluimos los números bueno mi masa es
de 3 kilogramos multiplicada por la
aceleración de la gravedad
qué es 9.8 pero para facilitarnos los
cálculos vamos a redondear los 10 metros
por segundo al cuadrado más los 5
minutos
si solo estuviera colgando la manzana
esto sería m x g pero aquí tenemos una
fuerza extra que está jalando la manzana
hacia abajo por lo que nuestra fuerza de
tensión con estos cinco newtons que van
hacia abajo va a ser igual a 35 35
minutos en el caso más sencillo eso
sería igual a m por g pero no siempre es
así
ahora si tuviera dos cuerdas que están
sosteniendo esta manzana pues ya tendría
dos tensiones aquí arriba ahora tendría
otra fuerza de tensión con la dirección
hacia arriba que haría en este caso pues
agregaría mi otra t que se suma porque
la dirección es hacia arriba que más te
es igual a dos t aquí tengo dos t y aquí
también tengo dos t para despejarte
simplemente tengo que dividir 35 newtons
entre 2 por lo que podemos complicar
cada vez más estos problemas agregando
alguna cuerda en otra posición o
agregando fuerzas hacia abajo y quizás
ustedes tengan la impresión de que cada
que hacen esto tienen que ser algo
diferente pero la realidad es que no
simplemente dibujan su diagrama de
fuerzas usan la segunda ley de newton
ponemos con cuidado las fuerzas
involucradas y despejamos aquella fuerza
que nos interesa y si los confunde el
por qué esta te es igual a 35 newtons
entre 2 es porque aquí ya tenemos dos
cuerdas que se están repartiendo la
atención de cargar esta manzana hacia
abajo tenemos 30 newtons de gravedad más
los 5 newtons que están jalando hacia
abajo 35 newtons hacia abajo y hacia
arriba tenemos las dos tensiones si
estas dos cuerdas están atadas en el
mismo lugar ambas van a cargar el mismo
peso entre las dos van a tener que
cargar 35 newtons por lo que cada una va
a cargar la mitad de eso y a partir de
uno de los problemas más sencillos pues
lo fuimos complicando poco
y esto se complica aún más si agregamos
algo con un ángulo por ejemplo tengo
aquí está atención en ángulo tenemos un
pizarrón que está colgado usando dos
cuerdas una cuerda está horizontal la
otra cuerda tiene un ángulo que tenemos
que hacer aquí quizás ustedes piensen
que hay que hacer algo diferente para
esto pero no lo resolvemos de la misma
manera primero dibujamos nuestro
diagrama de fuerzas seguimos teniendo
nuestra fuerza de gravedad hacia abajo m
por ge y para ser consistentes digamos
que este pizarrón también tiene una masa
de 3 kilogramos y también voy a tener mi
tensión que se mueve a la derecha no
apunta en esta dirección la atención la
atención no empuja solo jala por lo que
esta atención va a ir en esta dirección
está este 1
y en mi diagrama de fuerzas luces así
este este uno
y tengo una fuerza más tengo esta fuerza
horizontal aquí
que nuevamente no está empujando solo
está jalando pues es una cuerda está
jalando hacia la izquierda
a esto le llamamos t 2 y mi diagrama de
fuerzas va a tener esta t 2 acá y estas
son todas mis fuerzas aquí no tengo una
fuerza normal y muchas personas están
acostumbradas a dibujar siempre una
fuerza normal que iría así pero en este
caso no hay ya que no hay ninguna
superficie que esté tocando este
pizarrón simplemente está colgando
mediante estas dos cuerdas la únicas
fuerzas que lo mantienen arriba sería el
componente vertical de esta atención así
que estas son todas las fuerzas que
tenemos y después de hacer esto que
hacemos pues lo mismo que en el problema
de la manzana
vamos a usar nuestra segunda ley de
newton la aceleración es igual a la
fuerza meta dividida entre la masa qué
dirección vamos a usar pues no es muy
evidente aquí ya que tenemos fuerzas
horizontales y verticales y mi consejo
aquí es que ustedes se vayan por lo que
conocen aquí ya conocemos la fuerza de
gravedad conozco la masa que es de tres
kilogramos y también conozco la
aceleración de la gravedad 9
ocho metros por segundo al cuadrado
aunque en este caso lo voy a redondear a
10 así que esta fuerza es de 30 newtons
ya que 3 por 9.8 os redondeamos 3 por 10
es 30 y ya que conozca esta fuerza y
conozco su dirección pues voy a comenzar
con esta dirección ya que conozco ya
algo de esta dirección por lo que vamos
a calcular la aceleración en la
dirección vertical comenzamos con la
dirección vertical en el eje y y si nos
equivocáramos si eligiéramos la
dirección errónea pues no es el fin del
mundo simplemente elegimos la otra
dirección aquí sólo hay dos direcciones
que podemos elegir si una no es la
correcta pues elegimos la otra no hay
problema entonces es la aceleración
vertical y esto se encuentra sin moverse
está en reposo aunque si hubiera algún
movimiento pues lo ponemos aquí no hay
problema pero en este caso todo está en
reposo así que cero es igual que vamos a
poner aquí pues arriba va a nuestras
fuerzas verticales conozco está 30
minutos hacia abajo
ponemos menos 30 newtons ya que estos 30
minutos van hacia abajo y quedamos que
todo lo que iba hacia abajo iba a ser
negativo y todo lo que fuera hacia
arriba sería positivo esto es m&g pude
haberlo escrito como menos m&g que más
tengo bueno tengo ate uno de uno apunta
hacia arriba pero no puedo poner toda la
magnitud de uno aquí porque no todo este
vector apunta hacia arriba solo podría
hacerlo si te uno fuera completamente
vertical hacia arriba pero no lo es
parte de ello apunta hacia arriba y
parte de ello apunta horizontalmente así
que parte de este uno apunta a la
derecha y otra parte apunta hacia arriba
y esta parte es la que jala hacia arriba
ese componente es el que me interesa
pues es lo que ocasiona que esté
pizarrón permanezca colgado es la parte
que equilibra la gravedad y vamos a
llamar la t1 de este otro componente
este
1x así que aquí agregamos de 1 en la
dirección y eso
no son las únicas fuerzas que tenemos en
sentido vertical de 1 x no es vertical
es horizontal t 2 también es horizontal
por lo que t 1 y y fg son las únicas que
están en sentido vertical lo dividimos
entre la masa
multiplicamos ambos lados por m m por 0
sigue siendo 0 0 es igual a menos 30
newtons más
t 1
y vamos a despejar t 1 y aquí escribo t
1 y en ambos lados sumó 30 newtons por
lo que t 1 y es igual a 30 newtons
positivo lo que tiene sentido ya que
está t1 y es el único componente que
está equilibrando la fuerza de gravedad
y sabemos que están en equilibrio porque
no hay ninguna aceleración vertical por
lo que éste uno tiene que tener la misma
magnitud que la fuerza de gravedad
aunque en mi dibujo no son
proporcionales aquí debía haber dibujado
el vector de la misma longitud que el de
aquí abajo porque ambos son iguales para
poderse cancelar pero bueno esto es t1g
pero yo quiero saber cuánto vale t 1
cómo puedo encontrarte uno y cómo puedo
encontrarte 2
quiero conocer las tensiones y no
solamente el componente vertical de
éstas
estate uno lleva a estar relacionada con
este uno y va a estar relacionada
mediante el ángulo que está aquí no
importa cuál sea este ángulo yo puedo
decir usando trigonometría que el seno
de este ángulo ángulo theta es igual al
lado opuesto entre la hipotenusa en este
caso el lado opuesto a este ángulo este
uno y
dividido entre la hipotenusa y aquí la
hipotenusa es todo mi vector tensión que
pero despejará t1 se multiplicó ambos
lados por teu no me va a quedar de 1 por
seno de teta y si divido a ambos lados
entre seno de teta me va a quedar que
que uno es igual
de uno
dividido entre el seno de theta y aquí
conozco este uno de la dirección
vertical 30 newtons por lo que tenemos
30 el newton es mi fuerza recuerden que
este componente vertical tiene que
equilibrar la fuerza de gravedad y por
eso es que vale 30 newtons dividido
entre el seno del ángulo como vamos a
encontrar este ángulo bueno aquí arriba
tenemos un ángulo de 30 grados
pero queremos saber cuál es el ángulo de
aquí abajo si esto es 30 aquí va a ser
90 esto tiene que ser 60 estoy en un
triángulo y si este 60 y esto es 90 pues
esta parte de aquí va a tener que ser 30
por lo que este ángulo es de 30 grados
así que aquí tiene que ser mi seno de 30
grados
tengo 30 minutos dividido entre seno de
30 y el seno de 30 es un medio es 3.5
por lo que esto es 60 minutos y esto
puede verse medio raro pueden decirme a
ver espera un momento que uno es 60
newtons el peso de este pizarrón es de
30 newtons como es posible que la
atención en esta cuerda sea de 60
newtons bueno si la colgaremos con una
cuerda solamente y la ataremos en el
centro de masa tendremos una atención de
30 newtons como es posible que esto
tenga 60 newtons bueno sabemos que esta
parte de aquí es de 30 minutos ya lo
encontramos
porque tiene que equilibrar la gravedad
pero eso es una parte de todas las
fuerzas involucradas aquí
si parte de la atención total es 30 toda
la atención tiene que ser mayor que 30 y
en este caso es de 60 newtons así que es
por eso que en este caso es más grande
está en un ángulo este componente
equilibra la gravedad y el total de la
atención tiene que ser mayor que este
componente y ahora como calculamos de 2
pues no vamos a cambiar la estrategia
seguimos usando la segunda ley de newton
la aceleración es igual a la fuerza neta
entre la masa la aceleración en la
dirección horizontal es igual a la
fuerza neta en dirección horizontal
entre la masa seguimos con la segunda
ley de newton aunque ahora queremos
encontrar esta otra fuerza esta fuerza
es horizontal por lo que tiene sentido
que usemos nuestra segunda ley 10
minutos en el sentido horizontal
nuevamente si este pizarrón está en
reposo nuestra aceleración va a ser cero
y dibujo esa línea para mantener mis
cálculos separados
esto es igual a mi fuerza neta en la
dirección horizontal aquí tengo a t 1 en
la dirección de x de 1x y es positivo
porque va hacia la derecha
y consideramos que todo lo que va hacia
la derecha es positivo y lo que va hacia
la izquierda es negativo menos de 2 y
esto da t 2
no tengo componentes verticales entre 2
t2 apunta por completo en la dirección
horizontal dividimos esto entre la masa
multiplicamos la masa en ambos lados y
nos queda que 0 es igual a t 1 x menos
de 2
despejamos de 2 y nos quedan
si yo sumo t2 a ambos lados de la
igualdad me queda t 2 igual a t 1 x y
qué tan grande esté uno de la dirección
horizontal bueno sabemos que tf1 es
igual a 60 minutos y sabemos que te uno
en la dirección vertical es 30 minutos
entonces qué tan grande tendría que ser
esta parte bueno en lugar de usar el
seno aquí vamos a usar coseno tengo el
coche no detecta igual el coche no de
teta y sabemos que teta es 30 grados así
que es el coseno de 30 grados va a ser
igual al lado adyacente que esté 1 x
entre la hipotenusa y mi hipotenusa es
de 1 y sabemos que tf1 es igual a 60
despejó t 1x y me queda que éste es
igual si multiplicamos ambos lados por
60 newtons nos queda que es 60 minutos
por el coseno de 30 el coseno de 30 es
rey
cuadrada de 3 entre 2 por lo que tengo
60 minutos por raíz cuadrada de 3 entre
2 por lo que te 1x es igual a 60 entre 2
30 30 por raíz de 3 newtons y esta es de
1x por lo que puedo decir que aquí esto
es igual a 30 por raíz de 3 newtons
para mi segunda ley de newton en la
dirección horizontal esto es el valor de
t 2 de 2 es igual a 30 por raíz de 3
newtons y ya encontramos el valor de
esta fuerza lo que no nos debe de
sorprender ya que como no tenemos
aceleración en la dirección horizontal
esta fuerza tiene que equilibrar a esta
otra fuerza de aquí tienen que ser
iguales y encontramos que t 1x es igual
a 30 por raíz de 3 newtons por lo que te
2 tiene este mismo valor pero va en
sentido opuesto de manera que ambas
fuerzas estén balanceadas en la
dirección horizontal entonces
encontramos t1 de 60 newtons encontramos
de 230 por raíz de 3 newtons y ahora ya
podemos calcular el problema de nuestra
lata de chiles super picantes pero lo
haremos en el siguiente vídeo